like this is the society that we live in
if women women can have a child
and benefit from having that child
financially no no a man having a child
does not benefit financially from having
that child if that's the benefit that
you're talking about sorry paul but that
benefit that you're talking about right
the woman will get the house she'll get
the benefit she'll get whatever it is
that's given to her but is it enough to
give that child a decent quality of life
what does a man get
what does a man get he gets to go on
with his life he gets to choose whether
he stays or not
i'm saying no but he does though because
he he if he what he doesn't want to be
there
no you're right no but some of them
that's the accept but you're looking for
the exception rather than the rule where
are the men's shelters there's a million
women's shelters where are the men's
shelters
we don't have them no women
there's women's shelters yes
but the women's shelters are they really
helping the women as well they don't it
doesn't matter about that
the point is women the point is women
get bailed out for poor decisions they
either picked up they they made a bad
decision in who they picked
or they made a bad like or they got
themselves into a situation that they
shouldn't have been in but what happened
you know what happens to men that make
bad decisions they they they end up
homeless
yeah
look they're on the streets i've just
told you to sit there in a 2025k and see
my own daughter what i'm saying the mom
went to call and didn't have to pay now
because she went crying and went to
what's those women
women's shows the organization but
there's a particular one the giai or
i don't know basically it's women
basically you can get legal aids so
women get legal aid even me men don't
get legal aid i don't get legal aid no
i'm not saying no no no i'm not saying
you may not got illegal aid but you you
know a lot of women that have got legal
aid right yeah okay so that's what i
mean do you know any men that got legal
aid
there are some men that can't no do you
know any men ever got league weighed um
no no
and if a man if a man
if a man does want to get legal aid it's
harder for them there's more stuff
there's more stuff for women you know
they say what they're saying is there's
more than why aren't you working my
friend yeah you need to go and get it
for yourself yeah women get the man
hang on women get women get oh you know
what she's gonna need some help she's
gonna need some assistance let's give it
to her men don't get that generally in
society
the thing is i'm not saying we should or
shouldn't i'm saying men have been able
to suck it up and generally get on with
it
they have but the thing is women women
can be expected
to get some some assistance expection is
to do with you just said it yourself
speak loud
so if a woman is on low income she will
get legal aid if a man is on low income
he will get legal so you know
wait wait i don't know any men that gets
legal but i know men who are entitled to
legal aid because they don't have jobs
and because they're on benefits however
the issue is that men have the they have
the option to go and work because they
don't have the full responsibility of
the child the woman has no choice but to
stay at home and take the benefit which
is why you should stay with your man
who's my man no i'm just saying look at
the face
no no yours is a serious subject
again you've got generally speaking you
just said it you just said it yourself
and we're saying you know lots of women
this is why it's about generally
speaking where everyone what they're
basically saying women are more entitled
there are women organizations this thing
of if you say misogyny you want to talk
about i only know some people don't know
even know what they're saying
is yeah well and you even just
acknowledge that the woman gets the kids
the what yes yeah the woman yeah so
that's that's all sometimes i'm saying
that's not fair
so it should be why can't it be 50 50
and then go get like the woman go get a
job like you can work just like he can i
mean so so i don't un like even in that
statement you're still showing that it's
the system is against men do you know
how many single mothers
they have the kids they have the job
their choices
because some of them didn't have the
choice somebody do you know how many
single fathers are doing the same thing
as well but there's more like as a
single father there's not an a lot of
things there to help them as single
mothers there are things that are there
to help them more so you know where we
say well we've been saying in
here today that men don't really speak
so much about their issues right
if men came out and were vulnerable and
did speak about what they needed
if they were single parents and they
needed x y and z and they voiced that
they would get that i liked it but i
liked it
whenever whenever we say this is wrong
this is a poor thing that happens to men
the language is always put it back on
the men it's your fault you don't no no
no no you don't say this
i know but you're implying it because
you said oh if they only did this then
they would get that instead of just
saying like that's messed up
it is messed up i'm not saying it's
their fault but if we're saying that men
don't speak about their issues
then we have to acknowledge that if they
don't speak about their issues they're
not going to be comfortable to be
vulnerable to say hey i need help but
men understand like like facing the
consequences of their own actions where
women are just used to being bailed out
because if we if if women make a poor
choice society like like
society
bails her out there's women's shelters
there's not men's shelters but do you
know what they want you know
sorry one second bro she's not with that
is that
men are okay
understanding that women are the
quote-unquote weaker sex than us that
they may need things that we don't
generally need
i think what the problem has become is
when women have had those things
the ego started to grow
and the arrogance started to grow and
they wanted to use that now against the
same people men who realize no you're
going to need that because you're more
vulnerable than we are do you get what
i'm saying and i think
that's the whole feminist movement for
you really it might be the personal
point of view if the man
say for example they had the child
but they don't the second but
she's she's creating a hypothetical
apology if the man
did so let's just say they had a child
and he said for example i'm going to
take sarah as an example you provide for
your child right you do everything
you're supposed to do right
when i'm allowed when you're allowed but
when but you see that when i'm allowed
if you did it the way you wanted to
would the woman struggle
um
no okay
so if there were more in my opinion if
there were more men like you who did
what they were supposed to do
on a consistent basis we wouldn't have
this issue well and i'm not trying to
blame it on men i'm trying to blame i'm
i'm not even trying to blame no one i'm
saying for the men that don't do what
they're supposed to do i'm just saying
it's a shame because you can't blame the
women if you help them how they were
supposed to be helped they wouldn't be
crying if we if we picked better men we
wouldn't be crying
if we if we picked better men did you
know that 80 80 80 of women go after 20
of men if you want a guy over six foot
that's 15 percent of men
they're they're um i don't
i don't i don't know the exact stat but
it's like 18 percent
of
they're just
i can't remember this one but
it's a small percentage of men that
father all the kids so we keep picking
men that already have kids and we'll see
oh he didn't take care of the last kid
but oh maybe he'll he'll kick his chair
baby mothers are always fighting over
one another
do i do i feel bad if you picked a guy
that that didn't take care of the last
kid and now he's not taking care of your
kid no you picked him it's your own damn
fault
yeah men because
because women are generally spoken about
because women are generally attracted to
the same type of man um the type of man
displays that kind of confidence that
women like and so that type of man is
being um pursued by a lot of women
whereas there are what
sixty
sixty percent of men that women don't
even look at and there's a lot more
women and or we'll see oh he doesn't
have a job but let me still pursue him
like that that's a choice and and we we
keep putting it on the men and saying oh
but you're not taking care of the kid
but no you we pick him he's got he's got
potential